>>Teacher: The whole point
is that you're supposed
to experiment with ideas.
I would love it if you're on
the edge of what you understand.
>>Narrator: In the 21st century
effective teachers need more
than solid knowledge
of subject matter.
>>We call it the Think-First model.
>>Narrator: They should
know how to promote social
and emotional intelligence.
>>Teacher: When you are getting
provoked it's important to do what?
>>Student: Size up the situation.
>>Teacher: Good.
>>Narrator: Be comfortable
with instructional methods
like project-based learning.
>>Teacher: Alright, looking at how
the wheel is operating right now,
what might you change about it?
>>Narrator: And keep up with
rapidly evolving technologies
so they can facilitate
learning at any time and place.
>>Student: We could
do two if we wanted.
>>Teacher: Yeah.
>>Student: Right?
>>Teacher: Yep.
>>Ada: I don't believe that
good teachers are born.
I believe that we educate
people to become good teachers.
But I think good teachers have to
enjoy sharing their love of learning.
There has to be a passion
for learning that they want
to share with young people.
>>Teacher: This one,
do you know this one?
>>Student: Mullein?
>>Teacher: Right, mullein...
>>Narrator: Schools of
education are realizing
that good teachers are acting
as mentors, coaches, and guides,
encouraging students to take
charge of their own education.
>>Teacher: We want to
be careful we don't come
out in the end with your DNA barcode-
>>Narrator: High Tech High
in San Diego created its own
on-campus School of Education
to develop the kind of teacher
that will thrive in classrooms
that feature cross-curricular
projects.
>>Teacher: Yeah, I have them do
each this page in their table groups
and I went around to
each table group-
>>Larry: What I like to see
in a teacher is somebody
who has deep content knowledge
of their subject matter.
>>Teacher: And you want to check it
out, write down some observations,
what it smells like,
what it looks like.
>>Larry: Somebody who is passionate
about their subject matter.
>>Jeffrey: No, no, no, I like
how it bounces back and forth.
>>Larry: And people who are
very dynamic in their ability
to infect kids' curiosity.
>>Teacher: What is special
about this leaf that is going
to help it live in the understory?
>>Student: There's just a little bit
of light that will help it survive?
>>Narrator: In the best teacher
preparation programs educational
theory is integrated with
practical field experience,
strong mentors include
professors and classroom teachers,
there is ongoing support for
new teachers after graduation,
and continuous self-assessment
and reflection.
>>Teacher: Alright, this is a
silent exercise, and when it is
over we'll look at what we've got
and make some comments about it.
>>Narrator: The learning
doesn't stop with a credential.
Professional development
programs play a critical role
in creating successful teachers,
especially during the first
five years of teaching.
>>Teacher: Have you all
been doing the reading
or just watching the video?
Joseph?
>>Narrator: At Yes Prep in
Houston, Texas a full time dean
of instruction does periodic
classroom observations
and gives feedback to veterans
and new teachers alike.
>>Michelle: And we have a pretty
intensive rubric that we use so I go
into every classroom
approximately five times a year.
The majority of my time is spent
observing then debriefing with them.
And then after we talk
about high expectations
for this particular lesson then we'll
go into student-center classroom.
>>Narrator: Teachers
who are well-prepared
and trained stay on the job longer.
They have the ability to
fully engage their students.
They model social and emotional
intelligence and are able
to provide an invaluable human
touch that can make a difference
in their students' lives.
>>Teacher: What's that letter?
>>Student: "E".
>>What's that letter?
>>Student: "N".
>>Teacher: Look how smart you are;
you're so smart I can't even take it.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org